Good afternoon.
Welcome to talks at Google.
My name is Rebecca Moore.
I'm director of Google Earth and I'm
very pleased to welcome my dear friend,
Dr. Victoria Sweet, who just published
a new book called slow medicine,
the way to healing.
I've known Victoria for several decades
since nearly the start of her journey as
a physician,
including her 20 years practicing at
Laguna Honda Hospital in San Francisco and
taking time to get her phd in the
history of medicine during this period.
She's been on the front lines of dramatic
change in her profession as practicing
medicine has transformed into delivering
healthcare and not always for the
better. Her first book, God's hotel,
one widespread or awards in a claim
leading to a Guggenheim fellowship and the
time, pay attention to that word
because you will hear it today a lot.
The time for her to synthesize and
develop our ideas further around what she
called slow medicine and fast medicine
and how these two approaches are both
complimentary and necessary.
Googlers will particularly appreciate
that Victoria got her undergraduate degree
in mathematics from Stanford.
Go to Stanford and a so
please join me in welcoming
Dr Victoria. Sweet. Thank you.
Uh, thank you very much Rebecca for that
introduction and thank you all for being
here today and thanks to Google for
doing something this really unusual for a
big for profit company to
be willing to sponsor, uh,
books and speeches by authors.
It's,
it's a really wonderful thing and special.
I think it tells a lot about Google.
Um, I would like to add that, I know I do.
I get my mathematics degree at Stanford.
It was my major, but my minor was
classics and that is a stream.
This two things have, have woven
their way through through my life.
So what I would like to do this afternoon,
I'll speak for about 40
minutes and all be, um,
explaining kind of how I
actually got right here. Uh,
that's the first part of the talk.
In the second part,
they're going to want to talk about
what's going on with medicine and, uh, in,
during my career and what I think
we can do to make it better.
So I'm going to start with my,
yes. So the first one, first
thing you should know about me is that
I don't consider myself a natural born
doctrine.
And by that I mean growing up I never
watched doctor shows or went to a
volunteered in the hospital
and if somebody was sick,
I didn't want to hear about it or have
anything to do with them. And in fact,
the first time I had to draw blood
medical school, I passed out.
So definitely not a natural born doctor.
But what happened was at the end of
college I was looking for a way to
synthesize these two parts of myself, the
mathematics, the classics, the history,
the humanities and the sciences.
And I ran into the writings of Carl Jung,
the psychiatrist. He'd written a memoir
called memories, dreams and reflections.
And I ran into it by accident in the
library and I found myself and thrawled.
I wasn't enthralled first of all by the
meaning he expected from his own life
and also by the kind of
life he set up for himself.
This is a stone house he had built
for himself and the Lake Zurich.
And this is where he saw patients
in the morning and neurotic,
well paying patients in the morning
and illuminated manuscripts and studied
alchemy in the afternoon.
I thought this was a great life and
that's what I wanted to do when I grew up
and that's how I got to medical school
because I was going to be a union
psychiatrist.
Then it turned out I liked medical school
a lot more than I thought it would,
especially the last two
years of medical school.
When you finally get a chance
to see real patients. I,
I loved what's called the workup.
I loved the history taking the history
tied to figure out the patient's story
because there was so
much psychology to it.
Hearing what the patient
said and didn't say,
sing what the way he said or he,
she said what?
What the answer to the question and
then there was examining the patient.
It turns out I actually
liked touching people.
I particularly like the physical exam
because there was so much I could learn
from it about with the
patient had and didn't have,
and then there was putting it all together
in a diagnosis and the treatment and
the plant. It was a logical,
brilliant method. Nevertheless,
I continued my first idea and I went
into a psychiatric residency that was a
little bit naive.
So my psychiatric residency took place
in the only locked psychiatric ward in
our county. So consequently
the patients were not humans,
well paying neurotic articulated patients.
They were severely psychotic and
they responded a lot more to the
medicines we use and they did
to the talk therapy. I tried,
so after I got my license,
after that first year of internship,
I just went out and practiced medicine
for several years in various clinics and
it was fascinating because the county
clinics in the community clinics would get
waves of immigrants every time there was
a war or a rumor of war and they would
bring with them their diseases and also
their different way of looking at the
body.
I saw everything in those clinics.
I saw three cases of leprosy,
and this is right around here when I,
when I did this,
I saw almost every parasite there was
and saw many unusual diseases and it was
also interested in these different
ways of looking at the body.
And so after a while I decided that I
might as well bit that I liked medicine.
I went back and did a three years of a
regular medical residency and then I went
back to the community clinics.
The longer I practice medicine,
the more impressed I was by the logical
method of writing at a diagnosis and a
treatment. But it was also more and
more impressed by what this medicine,
modern medicine left out, which was of
course anything that wasn't a logical.
So after a while I started
reading, uh, alternative medicines,
natural apathy, homeopathy, Chinese
medicine, and Ayurvedic Medicine.
And for a while,
uh,
I even thought about learning Chinese
so I could understand Chinese medicine
from the inside or Sanskrit.
So I could understand Indian
medicine from the inside.
But eventually I decided that even if
I did get to that point that I could
understand them,
that their cultures were still two
different from my own to understand their
different ways of looking at the body.
It was just rather discouraging moment
that I discovered the writings of uh,
a very, uh, unusual 12th century woman.
Her name was Hildegard of
Bingen and she was a mystic.
She was a composer. Uh, she
was an artist. She was a,
she was a field login,
but she also has a turned out,
it was a medical practitioner that
you written a book on her medicine.
And as I stood there and read
her book in the library again,
I was impressed by the medicine that
she was recounting cause it wasn't the
medieval medicine that
expected tongue of new to,
I have frog medicine expected
from a medieval medical texts.
It was a real medicine for real patients
with real diseases I could recognize.
But it was based on a completely different
model of the body from our modern
medical model. I couldn't quite put
my finger on how it was different,
but I decided then and there that I was
gonna go back to school and get a phd in
medical history with Hildegard of,
of my focus.
But I didn't want to
stop practicing medicine.
I wanted to do this half time and I spent
a couple of months looking around for
halftime position,
which was rather difficult at the time
until finally I discovered I was offered
a position at a very unusual
hospital in San Francisco,
which is called Laguna Honda
Hospital attempt disco.
And when I drove over for the first
time and saw it high on that hill,
I wasn't taken aback.
There's about 20 years ago now,
it looked like a medieval monastery.
They had had red tile roof,
senate cream colored walls and it turned
in a bell tower where patients I turned
out, used to go up in smoke and uh,
I went to my interview and the medical
director took me around and I had never
seen a hospital like this need was on
62 acres of land in the middle of San
Francisco.
It had 1200 patients.
It was is he enormous grounds.
The patients were all got taken care
of on these old fashion a wards,
those open wards you see in the old
movies from the 1930s he had had an x ray
department where we could take our own
x rays and a lab with a microscope where
we could look at our own slides.
It had a a chapel,
a little small chapel that
was run by the county.
It had a chapel that actually looked
more like a church with stained glass
windows and I'm Polish wooden pews and
a very politically incorrect stations of
the cross along the walls.
And then we went out and the medical
director showed me the grounds,
which were enormous.
There was an aviary so that patients
could watch chickens hatch from eggs.
There was a green house so that patients
could pop plants and there was even a
barnyard for the patients could see
animals even if they were bed bound.
And we walked back to her office and she
offered me the job. Well, I didn't know,
I wasn't sure. I had never seen a
place like that before in my life.
But I was the only place that would
let me practice medicine part time.
So I said I would stay for two months
and they ended up staying for 20 years
cause it turned out to be a
fascinating place to practice.
And that was for one specific reason.
It had originally been called
the San Francisco almost south.
This was the first rendition of Laguna
Honda in an 1860s and the aunt's house
was actually how we used to
take care of just sick poor.
Before there was health insurance, we had
a way of taking care of the sick poor.
And that was this system that was the
big old county hospital where anybody
could show up and get taken care of.
And then if they need more care than that,
we had some place to send them.
So this was where in the old days we could
send people who were mentally ill who
needed more care, who were unemployed
or just been let out of prison.
We actually had a system and Laguna Honda
was the San Francisco [inaudible] and
it's how I got the title for my last
book because this is the system that we
have came from France
and Europe in general.
And in French, the word for alms
house is hotel. Gm is God's hotel.
So that's why I got the name.
And the reason I ended up staying so
long is because typically the Almshouse
would get the bottom one
10th of 1% of patients.
So my patients were all three
standard deviations from the mean,
any meat, they were the
tallest, they were the shortest,
the fattest.
And they were the dentist.
They were the oldest and the youngest
and the nicest and the immune system.
Any patients I ever had.
And because the whole catchment
area was San Francisco,
it's time with 600,000 people.
Uh,
if a disease would occur in
one in 100,000, I'd say couple.
So it was fascinating place medically.
I just went through the rare diseases
in Harrison's textbook of medicine and
check them off as they would come up.
So it was a fascinating place to practice.
And an ended up staying for 20 years.
There's also a wonderful place to practice
because healthcare efficiency had not
yet arrived.
We were over the hill to the poor house
literally and people kind of left us
alone. I mean we had standards and things
people paid attention to what we did,
but mostly I had something that
doctors today mostly don't have.
That is the time to take
care of my patients,
to properly examine them, to figure
out what was actually wrong with them,
to get the right diagnosis and the right
treatment. And the longer I was there,
the more impressed I was by not only how,
um,
how, um, satisfying that
was for me as a dog,
but how efficient it was even from a
healthcare efficiency point of view.
Then I'll give you an example.
The typical patient at Laguna Honda
would arrive with on between 15 and 26
medications of which they only
needed about four or five.
But no other doctor had had the
time to go through the chart,
go through the patient, figure out whether
they actually needed that medicine,
maybe even try and taking them off
that medication to see how they did.
I found that most of the patients could
be handled very well in five medications.
So I was taking them off
between 10 and 15 medications,
which if you figure it out,
um,
economically is incredibly cost effective
for the extra few hours of time it
took me. So I was quite happy there.
And then I, meanwhile of course,
I'd gone back to study,
um,
this is actually what I call
the efficiency of inefficiency.
Meanwhile,
I'd gone back as I decided to do to get
my phd in medical history with Hildegard
of Bingen as my focus.
And what I decided to do was to really
learn Hildegard's medicine as if I were a
student by reading her medical text
in its original language and by
understanding what people
were doing around her. Uh,
so I took classes in learned Latin
cause she wrote in Latin and I learned
medieval Latin cause she read
actually in medieval Latin.
I learned medieval German and German
because that's what the secondary
literature was in and learn
paleography and code ecology.
So I could actually read the handwritten
texts, which they had back then.
And he also experimented because I
figured if I had been her student in the
Middle Ages,
I'd sort of have a sense of using her
different recipes and prescriptions.
So I planted a medieval or garden and
I brewed up some of her potions and
Syrup's I uh,
tried her medicinal beers and I baked
some of her antidepressant cookies.
And what I've found over time I got more
and more interested in the difference
between Hildegard's model of the body
and our model of the body because they
were clearly very different.
Our model of the body is fundamentally
based on the idea that the body is a
machine and the doctor is a
mechanic looking for what's
broken and trying to fix
it,
repair it or replace it.
Hildegard's model was very different.
I gradually learned over the years the
guards model was much more of the body as
a plant rather than as a machine. And
then doctor, more like a gardener.
And a mechanic.
What's the difference?
The difference is that someone
has to fix a broken machine,
but a plant can heal itself.
Hildegard had a name for uh,
the power of a plant deal itself and
she called it Verdad toss from the Latin
Veritus that means green. So it was
the greening power of a plant to grow,
to produce seeds and to repair
itself when it was injured.
And she believed that uh,
human beings also have this power.
And then the job of the doctor was more
to remove what was in the way of the
patients for at a task and to support it
with the basics then to do something to
the patient.
So this was a very interesting model
and it took me years to understand how a
plot to apply it to the
patients I had at Laguna Honda.
But gradually I began to see that not
only could I help a patient by figuring
out what diagnosis they actually had,
once I had the diagnosis to step back and
see what was in the way of [inaudible]
and what could I do to support it. The
longer I practice medicine within a Honda,
the more I realized that this was a very
helpful way of looking at patients and
I began to think of it as sort of that
slow medicine as opposed to the fast
medicine I also use, which is so effective
for what I considered Beth disease.
So for instance,
if you get to come to the hospital because
you have appendicitis and you need an
appendectomy or you come to the hospital
in you had or having a heart attack and
you need an angioplasty,
or even if you have cancer,
this is when what I would call
by contrast, fast medicine,
our modern medicine based on the model
of the body as a machine works great,
but after your appendectomy,
after angioplasty and
after your chemotherapy,
this is when modern medicine
with this idea of coming in,
fixing what's broken falls down.
And what I learned at Laguna Honda is
when I used both models together first
fast and then slow medicine,
the patients did the best.
They did remarkably well.
Many of them were actually able to go
home sort of unexpectedly during the 20
years I practiced medicine while he was
practicing medicine at Laguna Honda,
we eventually got discovered a and are
Alison days of having enough time began
to disappear and uh,
first by health care efficiency experts
who showed up one day walking through
the place and horrified to discover
the aviary and the greenhouse and
particularly the open wards.
And the Department of Justice finally
eventually showed up and told Laguna Honda
that they were going to have to tear the
place down and rebuild a new healthcare
facility that had private rooms for
all the patients rather than keep the
patients on the open wards.
Um,
and at that point I decided to take some
time off and write a book about what
I'd seen there. That was my first
book and also to think about, uh,
what I've seen so far in
my life as a physician.
It seemed to me when I thought about
that in my life as a physician, um,
the pendulum of healthcare is swung
from the personal to the efficient.
And I've been more and
more impressed by what, uh,
that leaves out.
So for instance,
the results of the kind of health care
efficiency we've had over the last 20
years as you can see,
is that healthcare costs have kept rising
no matter what healthcare economists
have tried to do.
They've tried to do all kinds of screens
for getting a coat of healthcare.
And this is not true just in the
United States, but across the world,
healthcare costs keep rising every
year despite DRGs and h emos and manage
health care systems,
everything.
We've tried trying to understand what
was going on in the system as a whole.
I decided to look at Laguna Honda
specifically and asked myself what was had
gone on there in the last 20 years.
So,
so I figured out that in the last
20 years as a cost cutting measure,
the patients we had had gone from about
1,178 down to 780 this was as a cost
cutting measure. So we were taking care
of a lot fewer patients. Of course,
correspondingly,
the number of doctors we had went
down was cut from 32 to a nine and
correspondingly also the clinical stuff
that's the nurses and the therapists and
the social workers was also
cut as a cost cutting measure,
cost cutting measure from um,
about 1500 to 1200.
And yet at Laguna Honda every
year to budget had increased.
So I asked me what accounted for that
and I realized that even though the
patients were fewer and the doctors
were considerably fewer and the clinical
staff had been cut,
the total staff was actually the same.
There were more and more
administrators every year.
What did all those administrators
do? I asked myself, well,
what I realized was that
when I thought about it that the one
thing we had more of at Laguna Honda, uh,
at the time,
at the end of my time there,
then at the beginning of the time
we're forms. So when I first got there,
we had paper charts and we had two
single page forms in the chart.
And the day before I left Laguna Honda,
I pulled out one of the paper charts just
randomly and I started looking through
it and I counted how
many forms there were.
And there were 43 forms in that chart
and none of them were single page forms.
They were 10 page,
20 page.
There were so many forms that the
charts would explode from the forms and
medical records had to show up
and thin out the doctor's notes.
Okay.
And this to sort of clarify things because
I do have someone have a mathematical
mind.
I created this chart at the time
when I was figuring this out. Okay,
now this is working.
So this is a try to create it at the
time on a Napkin as Becca pointed out the
other day. Um, so these are the patients
going down. I was trying to figure out,
understand the system. They're the
doctors going down. There's the, uh,
budget going up, the clinical staff, the,
the total staff saying about the same.
And this was the number of forms.
What I realized is is that if current
trends continued by 2024 there would be no
patients at Laguna Honda,
there'd be two doctors there.
It'd be a staff of 1400 a budget of
$275 million and an infinite number of
forms.
And I decided this is,
I began to think of this
as doing this with more.
And the thing that's interesting about
it is and crucial that it is exactly the
same as being the thing has been
happening in the country as a whole.
Let me give you a show. You what I mean.
So this was the country as a whole.
So if you look at the growth of
its physicians and administrators,
here's what you find.
Okay,
so I'll interpret this a little bit
for you. These are the number of docs,
percentage growth. So it's about
double. So the dots about doubled in,
in tandem with the
population is about double.
So those are about the same number of
dots per patient and vice versa as there
always have been. The yellow is
a number of administrators there,
35 times as many administrators
as there used to be.
And as you can see,
just like [inaudible] to the budget
is continued to go up every year.
And what do all those docs do? What of
all those administrators do, I should say,
well, this just is an interesting,
this was HHS paperwork. Really.
They should take the electronic
computer work and millions of hours,
millions of hours.
Just in the last 10 years,
it has doubled from 350 million hours.
It has doubled to almost
700 million hours.
Why? Well, what's happened is,
is that because of all of this paperwork
that the administrators have generated
for various reasons,
we've ended up in a situation where your
doctor doesn't have enough time to look
at, uh, patients anymore.
This is a sentence I've heard over and
over again in the last five years as I've
gone around and spoken about the book,
and I put it,
I don't know if you can see
when you're sitting here,
but this was a rather scandalous.
I'm drawing that appeared in the Journal
of American Medical Association a few
years ago. Uh, a doc had it published.
It was a mother who brought it to him.
It was a drawing by her
five year old daughter, uh,
about my visit to the doctor and uh,
can't see it too well,
but this is the daughter sitting on the
exam table behind it as mom holding a
little baby and at friend I believe.
And this is the doctor who's
looking at the computer.
This is where we're spending our time.
And um,
from experience in general and experience,
particularly at Laguna Honda,
I believed in order to have
a good healthcare system,
we actually need to put inefficiency
that is unregulated free time for the
doctors and the nurses to have the time
to look the patients and to get off the
computer.
And the question then becomes,
how can we get that time back?
Because as you've just seen,
we have actually the same number of
doctors and patients as we've always had,
but the doctors are spending a bunch of
time not with the patients so that the
patient doesn't feel lifted anymore.
And isn't looked at it anymore.
So when I was thinking about
this, trying to figure out, okay,
so how could we get the time
back? I asked myself, well,
what do we spend our time on in a way
time is the Verint Atossa healthcare.
So I can do a written toss
analysis and ask myself, well,
what are, what is in the way of doctors
having enough time with patients?
What do doctors spend their time on?
So I came up with three
fundamental things.
Doctor spend their time on forms when I
called fast administration as opposed to
slow administration and lousy
electronic health records.
By forms,
I mean this whole contraption that has
come upon us with electronic health
records and administration
screens, logins, alerts,
email scripts and this that are based
on this whole idea that if it's not
documented, it did, it didn't
happen. And if it is documented,
it did happen. And we can talk
about that a little bit. Um,
and fecund what I'm thinking
of is fast administration,
which I consider a problem with style.
This idea by administrators that
if they come up with a form,
they're done, they come up with a
paradigm, a script for us to follow.
The problem is solved and last and really
mainly the easiest thing to fix to get
doctors back their time. Electronic
health records that take all our time.
And this is what I'd like to sort of
zero in now and the the for for a little
bit about the problem with electronic
health records and how I think we can
actually get back to doctors back
some of our time with patients,
some of our free time,
some of our inefficient time.
So we can sit down with patients and
look at them and actually examine it.
So what's happened in the past about
10 years is electronic health records.
We used to use the paper charts,
right,
which had their biggest flaw with paper
charts was that if you went to the
emergency room and having happened
and then you came back to your doctor,
they couldn't tell you what,
nobody knew what was going on.
We had to get them to send us to
xerox things and send the papers.
So what 10 more than about 10 years ago
they do was that if we had electronic
health records on the computer and
you went to the emergency room and had
something done,
it would magically appear in your
doctor's office and the doctor's computer.
And so that's kind of was the way that
electronic health records were, um,
envision.
But that's not what happened because,
because there's so much money in
healthcare these days and so much money in
electronic health records at this point,
the last time I checked, there were 1000,
104 profit electronic health record
companies and they're engineered so that
they don't talk to each other. So it's
actually even worse than it used to be.
So how bad is it? Well, um,
doctors have ended up,
so first of all,
electronic health records haven't
done what they should've done,
but in addition had been used to acquire
big data for the pharmaceuticals,
marketing and advertising.
And the doctor has been right in the
middle of that doctor has been plumped in
front of the electronic health records,
which are based on a model of based on
an old billing model that comes back from
the 1970s and is incredibly clumsy.
So clumsy that in a Stanford study doctors
were actually spending 70% of their
time on the computer.
But in a more sort of shocking study,
Kaiser got tired of hearing how whiny
their doctors were about how much time you
spend in the computer.
So they actually decided to see how much
time do our doctor spin on the computer
and they picked two hospitals
and they spend two months, uh,
actually keeping track of all the
stroke doctor, all the keystrokes.
And then they added all that time up and
they divided by the number of doctors.
This was in two separate hospitals over
two months and they discovered that the
doctors out of an eight hour day,
we're spending 10 hours on the computer.
So this is where our time is going.
And we could get it back
if we had electronic health
records that only took as
much time as the paper records,
which were,
which would take about 15% of our time.
So in a 15 minute visit,
they take two and a half
minutes of time rather than, uh,
taking more than 15 minutes
of that 50 minute time,
we could get the doctors off the computer
back to doing the kind of care that I
was able to give a Laguna Honda where
we can actually get the right diagnosis
and the right treatment. So that's
actually what I'm focusing on now.
And one of the reasons I wanted to speak
to, uh, to this particular audience,
cause I think it's very possible to
create an electronic health records that's
simple,
that's cheap,
that takes like two and a half minutes
instead of 15 minutes and that everybody
could use and would want to use. So, um,
some of my rather larger ideas for getting
control would be to have the opposite
of the three things I had before
about what we spend our time on.
So we could start in terms of forms with
a lock for the conservation of forms.
So my experiences that we have enough
forms already and that we don't need any
new forms.
And I think in most hospitals situations
that when an administrator comes up
with a new form, they should find at least
one form of equal length to get rid of
second of all, uh, slow administration.
I think that if administrators would
think and would realize that every time
they send an email, organize a
meeting or come up with a new form,
they are directly taking
time away from the dock.
And last we need the electronic
health records, that preserve story.
Because the problem with electronic health
records based on the billing platform,
I don't know if anybody
hears ever seen them,
but they make it literally impossible
to s to understand what's actually going
on with your patient.
And the last thing that I think we need
to do in our healthcare system is to
also start some experiments
with being slow.
And some of the ideas I've come up
with for that is to just in a hospital
situation to have a slow medicine clinic
where the doctor would get as much time
as they need it with patients.
That's a novel idea,
a slow medicine beds so that we had a
few beds in the hospital where patients
could be admitted when they needed to
work up instead of getting piecemeal being
sent all over town when they get sick
and finally a slim at us and consult
service.
That would be the equivalent of an
oncology consult service or a cardiology
consult service,
but it would be for slow medicine for
the patients that we end up as doctors
getting in the hospital that are so sick
and complicated and we know we can not
figure it out what's going on with him
and we have to discharge them. Instead.
We could call it the slow medicine
consult service and have them arrive and
figure the patient out because in the end,
I'm not a complete pessimist
about healthcare. I'm a
pessimist and an optimist.
I think that healthcare
is with healthcare,
the glass is half full and
half empty in this way.
That in a lot of ways, uh, we've done
a fantastic job with fast medicine.
That this model of the body
as a machine and the doctors,
a mechanic has been incredibly powerful.
Uh,
if you look at what's happened over the
last hundred and 50 years in medical
history and nobody would
ever want to go back to, um,
to practicing medicine the way
we did even 20 or 30 years ago.
But on our way to fast medicine this,
I did,
the doctors would have enough time to
get the right diagnosis to examine the
patient to get the right
treatment has sort of disappeared.
And I think we need to go back and re
institute this second way of looking at a
patient for more on my book,
which some of you have.
And last, uh, I always like to
remember who in the end won that race.
So thank you very much for your time.
We'll have some questions.
Thank you.
I do have a question to start with,
but people please think
of questions for Dr Suite.
So you're here at Google and a big focus
for us now is machine learning and AI,
which is being applied to all facets of
human endeavor and actually creating a
lot of breakthroughs.
Um,
do you have any thoughts on how machine
learning and AI could in fact play a
role in solving this problem
with electronic medical
health records that lose
the story?
Dr Spending too much time as data
entry clerks in thoughts on that?
Yeah, I do. So, so that's really
the issue of the hour, right?
There's 1100 different electronic
health records systems,
but they all look exactly the same.
They're all fundamentally the same.
And um,
they all lose the story there.
Little bits of information. They're
boxes that the docs have filled out.
The old paper charts,
we're basically books.
They were basically books and they
preserve the story of that patient.
They were books because they had pages
and they went through time that a
beginning and a middle and an end.
And this was incredibly useful as a doc
because you could go through and you
could read about how the patient first
come in and the things that were done and
with the nurse thought and with the social
worker didn't what meds they were on,
what labs.
It was very useful for preserving
the story and then what happened when
electronic health records came in
because they were built on this buidling
platform,
electronic health or as a,
we look at today with the doctors all
looking at a screen and it's a screen with
boxes and alerts and Login,
so the dog is sitting
there logging things in.
Pharmacies got a whole different section,
nursing as a different section and these
are all little boxes and you cannot
figure out from the electronic health
records what's gone wrong with the person.
I know this because my own father got
sick a couple of years ago and was
admitted to a hospital with the wrong
diagnosis and this particular hospital at
the time,
the doctors and nurses were actually
reading God's hotel and their book club,
so I was a bit of a VIP.
Nevertheless,
I could not get those docs
to change his diagnosis.
They'd thought he'd had a stroke,
but he hadn't had a stroke.
He has a seizure and he had a history
of seizures and we all knew he had
seizures. I couldn't get them to
focus. They even tried to change the,
the, the, the diagnosis and
the electronic health record,
but they couldn't change it.
So every time a new shift of
doctors and nurses came down,
they continued to treat my dad with,
uh, the treatment for a stroke.
And eventually he was on so much medicine,
medicine for the stroke and then medicine
for the side effects of the medicine
for the stroke and the
medicine to the blood,
kind of this sort of thing that he was
clearly going to die in the hospital.
So I was rather worried about him and I
realized the only way I could really get
them out of the hospital was to convince
the doctors that we thought we had
decided he was a hospice
level, uh, patient.
And we were wanting to just let him die.
So once they accepted that,
they let us take him home.
And I took him off all the medicines that
he was on and he had his 95th birthday
last about two months ago and cut
his own cake with a very large knife.
I might add. He did it on purpose. Um,
so I thought perhaps I'd missed something,
right because I couldn't,
there was no chart for me to
look at and I was worried, well,
maybe did have a stroke.
I mean, maybe I'm wrong.
So I asked for those
electronic health records,
his electronic records from 10 days
and I got them and it was amazing.
I took me four hours to go through those
electronic health records of my dad's.
There were 810 pages.
I had two questions I
was trying to answer.
What medications was he on at any
particular time and why had they made the
diagnosis of stroke?
And I could not figure it out.
I couldn't figure out anything.
It was just page after page of,
it was just,
there was no way,
and I spent four hours and I
knew what I was looking for.
So nobody who came to see him when
they looked at those electronic health
records could possibly a figured
out what was wrong with him.
So when you compare these beautiful
old fashioned paper charts,
it would have been easy.
I would have just gone through and looked
at as original diagnosis how we got it.
I would have turned back
and looked at the labs,
which would have been in a section,
I would have looked at the x rays,
I could have seen the nurse's notes,
I could have followed
the doctor's narrative.
I could have followed this
story would have been a snap.
So my idea is that we take this model,
this old fashioned model that's made
out of paper and we just turned it into
electronics, right? So we have
an electronic paper chart,
um, that preserves the story.
And how would we do that? Well,
so my imagination is that we have, we
already had this technology, right?
It's called an Ebook,
right?
So why not just use this idea of an
ebook for our electronic health record?
So if you, for instance, came into
my office, you're a new patient.
We have some Hipaa privacy protected cloud
that I can take a new chart out of it.
That's your chart and it looks like a book
like look books. It's on the computer,
but it looks like a book.
Right. And I should be able to,
I think I should be able to,
if I want, if I like to write,
how come I can't like handwrite a note
or if I like to dictate why can't,
if I like to type, I should be able to
do that. If I want to write in French,
I should be able to do that.
Right?
I should be able to write the narrative
of what happens and my physical exam,
I should be able to turn that chart
around, go look at fluffy the chart.
Right? Why can't we do that? And then that
would mean that if we did it this way,
then when I'm done with your chart,
I put it back in the cloud.
Let's suppose you have to
go to the emergency room.
They can just go take that
chart out of the cloud. Right.
And and write right it with themselves.
I'm sure we can do that.
Um, and so then the problem becomes, well,
what do we do? Because these electric,
one of the reasons electronic health
records have been used this ways for
billing. And the second
reason is because of big data,
right?
Big Debt is very valuable.
This idea that you can
figure out instantly how many
patients have hypertension
or what, how many patients this, this
kind of information is very valuable.
Uh, just financially it's very valuable.
Twilio, the marketing is valuable,
but pharmaceuticals,
it's value in the healthcare industry as
a whole to right now what we have is we
have the docs acting fundamentally as
data care providers. That's what we do.
We had a care provider, that's
a new one, right? We put,
that's our job.
We spend 110% of our time in front of
the electronic health records simply
entering data so that big data can be
produced so that big data can be sold and
used by these companies.
And so what I don't seem to me,
Becca and I have actually talked
about this, is with art. If,
if artificial intelligence can
do all these marvelous things,
why can't they take my handwritten
notes and all this stuff and just stick
artificial intelligence
between the unnecessary big
data and my electronic paper
chart.
And if artificial intelligence turned
my chart into all the big data you want,
why do I have to do it
works for me.
So that is a, that is a your challenge.
Yes. That's why I challenge Google. Okay.
But the gauntlet is now thrown.
Yes.
I think we should do that because if we
could do that, it would be phenomenal.
We could have doctors who could
spend two and a half minutes,
we'd have our 12 and a half minutes
back with patients to examine them.
The big data people who
like all that stuff,
they'd still be happy and you
guys could do something fantastic.
And I think it would be very interesting
for artificial intelligence to look at
that as a problem.
Right.
So I have one more question,
but then I want to want to
let other people do it too.
So in the news this week,
um,
I think it was just like yesterday,
the day before was suddenly now
announced that some of the health,
you know,
policy setters are,
have changed the standard for hypertension
and they've lowered the level of your
blood pressure at which they consider
that you have a problem and should go on
medication.
And I think I saw yesterday that now
50% of the adult population is now
considered hypertensive.
And in fact then I heard on NPR last
night something about someone who was sort
of an apologist for this was saying,
but it's okay.
We've determined that it's safe to
medicate people at these lower levels of
blood pressure. So it's
fine. I that alarming
and I just wondered if you
had any thoughts on this.
Okay.
Yes, I do have thoughts. Well, well,
so my first thought actually was,
so they've been doing this
for decades and decades,
so long ago when I was in medical
school and they had actually,
okay.
So the way the docs
determine what's, what's, uh,
what's high and what's low is
we don't really know. Actually,
it's mostly statistical.
We basically decide one standard
deviation from the mean or two standard
deviations from the mean by definition.
That's that's what we do
because we don't a priori,
we wouldn't know what a normal sodium
is though we didn't even know in normal
sodium as we do billions of sodiums and
people and then we declare these to be
normal within let's say one standard
deviation and everything else to be
abnormal and then sometimes we'll be
able to connect up a disease state or a
symptom with those abnormalities.
Yes, so with hypertension,
that was done in around the 60s and
seventies and the original definition of
hypertension was actually,
I may be one of the only people that
remember this was actually about 180 over
110 I was two standard
deviations from the mean.
Okay,
so that,
and that was correlated with significant
kidney problems when you have the high
blood pressure,
heart problems and extra strokes.
So that actually was actually shown
is evidence then over the years.
But that doesn't, that's two
standard deviations. What do you get?
7% of the people who are taking your
medications, right? That's not very much.
Right.
That's not very good.
So about about 20 years
ago that they lowered the,
they just randomly lowered and said,
well now it's going to be one
standard deviation from the mean,
which is 160 over 90
which nobody has ever,
ever correlated with actual damage,
but they just assumed if really
high blood pressure was bad,
then kind of this, this was still high.
It was one standard deviation mean well.
So then we had an an epidemic of high
blood pressure because suddenly we had 15%
of people had rights. Touristically
you guys are all mathematicians.
Once you go from two standard
deviations to one standard deviation,
you have 15% so you,
oh my God,
we have this epidemic because he used
to be 7% of people that hypertension,
now 15% of hypertension. So, but then we
have 15% more people taking medications,
which is very useful. So then
about think you're being sarcastic.
15 years ago we declared that
140 over 90 was a hypertension.
So then we had about 20% of
people were now hypertensive.
About 20% of people and
then the cardiologist got
together and decided that any
amount of blood pressure was bad for you.
They did.
Did remember they did do that.
Um,
but this is that they didn't really
officially declare it into this last week
where they've lowered it
once again down to one 30,
which falls actually with
way within the mean, right?
The mean of a blood pressure.
So consequently 50% of it's not
surprising that 50% of people now have
hypertension with a definition.
How would they not? Right.
Just statistically,
and that means 50% of people are
going to be on medications and um,
do these medications have side effects?
Yes,
they all have side effects. Okay.
Anyway, I, I'm asking too many questions.
Anyone else have a question for Dr
Suite or comment? Comment, comment?
I have a microphone. Okay,
great. Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah.
Actually
how much does that mean shifting
over time though, since the 60s.
What do you mean what you said it's so
many standard deviations from the mean.
That's right now
is that the itself over time?
So the main I switched you're saying?
That's a really interesting question.
That's actually a very good question.
As far as I know the mean is still the
average ish is still about one 20 over 70
as far as I know. I mean that's
actually a real interesting question.
I don't know the answer to that.
I don't know if anybody does.
Do you know what you mean offhand?
I think it's still one 20 over 70 it's
just they keep coming down just like
they've done with statens. It's exactly
the same model. I mean status you're,
you're elevated cholesterol
was two standard deviations
from the mean which was
going to be an Ldl,
the bad cholesterol of like 180 right
and then they went to 160 and then they
went to 130 which again
meant that 50% of the people,
not surprising where hypercholesterolemic
because that was like within 50% of
the people had an Ldl of one 30 and
then the cardiologist declared that it
doesn't really matter and we should
have as low cholesterol as possible.
Even though the white matter of your
brain is white because it's made out of
cholesterol
and okay.
You want me puts in and your sex
hormones are made out of cholesterol.
Vitamin D is actually, you know,
d one d hydroxy cholesterol, so,
okay. Yes. All right. Um, mescaline. Yup.
I get your name right.
It's selling
Selene. Yes, correct.
So I will say my question about forms
and administrators for later maybe,
um, but I'm, I'm more curious, but maybe,
maybe I'll start with the preface that,
you know,
we're a part of a technology company
and it certainly feels like the world is
moving faster and faster and we want to,
you know,
whether it's multitasking or
enabling people to move faster,
you put a lot of onus on the
medical system and doctors
to slow the system down.
It seems like to not treat the
body like a machine yet. What,
what are your thoughts from a
patient's perspective? Um, the, the,
the ability to take some ibuprofens when
I have a headache and solve the problem
is, you know, it's nice to hand
that off to the doctor and say,
why are you prescribing me? I prefer
orphans, but I can get this off the shelf.
How do patients approach
medicine differently and
slow things down and look for
longer solutions, more
holistic solutions? Okay.
That's a really thoughtful
question. Thank you. Um,
well,
you know what I would say is this,
I think there's actually two flavors of
patients to believers or people really.
Some people really like medications.
They like manZ , like labs.
They like going to the doctor, they
like, they just like it, they like meds.
And then there's a whole other group
that don't like meds of which I happen to
belong to them.
And what usually happens with docs
in an open system is the docs like to
prescribe meds and just
naturally practice this way.
Collect patients who liked
to have medications. There's,
there's a whole lot of people
believe in meds, right?
But I'm not one of them either
as a doctor or as a patient.
And I would tend to collect patients who
think like me. So I don't think it's,
you know,
just one or the other.
I think for the people who are
reluctant to take meds, um,
they don't usually take
meds you very much.
And if they can get away with just
taking something off the shelf,
sort of why not? Um, so,
okay.
I think that's how we would answer
that question. I'm not sure if I get,
if I got to the nub of it, which, cause
you started out with talking about,
you know, everything moving faster
and faster and that is a patient,
how can you get things to slow down in
an [inaudible]? He thinks his patient,
it says a person. I mean,
I think, so. This is again,
maybe a little off from me talking about,
but you know,
I think as far as our health goes,
we couldn't live in a society that was
more difficult to be sane and centered
and enjoy your life then the
society we live in right now.
Okay.
And I think, you know, sane
actually is from Sonos,
which means healthy inland and health,
which has solos actually
is connected to salvation.
Then I like the one that's hello,
which actually means health to you.
Cause the old English hall was held
and they're all related to this idea of
wholeness.
So Paul and how and how health and wealth,
I think I could looked that up your,
but I decided the other day,
I think wealth fits into
this wholeness model.
We're fragmented, our attention
is fragmented. Our, our,
we're just in this kind of piecemeal
sort of state and I think it's not a good
state to be in.
Another question, building on sleeves
thing. I think he says, you know,
I think it's separating
symptom from the source.
So if you have a headache
and that's a symptom,
you said I can take an Advil and that
will go away and you can just keep doing
that for awhile,
but you're not addressing the root cause.
So if I can treat a symptom I'll do with
myself, but if I can't get past that,
then that's where I go to. The doctor
helped me figure out what's going on.
Great answer. Thank you. Won't
you're supposed to comment on,
oh, I'm totally good with
it. It's exactly right.
That's exactly it is. If you can make it
go away on your own and that's, you know,
then I don't have a problem with that
actually. I think that's a good way to go.
That's your measure of efficiency though.
Are you looking at church and efficiencies
through that headache? Headache today?
It took a bill and went away.
I looks like it's extremely efficient,
but if every single day I'm taking this
pill and I'm constantly dealing with
that over the longterm,
that's extremely inefficient and
if I treat the source of that,
it takes me longer to treat the source,
but it solves it for much longer duration
and therefore it's much more efficient
in the loan.
Could answer. I just, it's super
thank you. Two so means point.
I think it's very hard for certain
segment of patients to get over that.
They want the quick fix.
So in some ways many physicians
respond to that by prescribing.
You know, I think many of, and
I speak as a physician myself,
many of us would like to sit down,
talk to our patients, spend time,
and sometimes patients like me, you
know, talk, I don't have time for this.
I'm not gonna invest in my health
care. I just want, you know,
give me the antidepressant
and I'll feel better.
And I have time for therapy later,
but I don't have time for that right now.
So I think there's this whole sea change
that has to also start from paint the
patient point of view, actually wanting
to invest time in there and themselves.
So if you ever see a thousand
patients, you don't have time. Correct.
Anyone else? One last question maybe. Um,
do you feel that you
as a clinician that a,
you are alone in this or as you go around
and you're talking with other doctors
and nurses and so on around the country,
is this message of slow
Madison resonating?
Okay.
Yeah, it sure is. And I,
I sometimes wish I was a lot more about
the general rather than a philosopher
because there's a whole movement
that is brewing out there is,
there's so much frustration among
doctors and nurses especially,
I mean as much nurses,
doctors that were just stuck
in front of the computer.
It's just maddening.
So there's a huge,
I I've spoken to like
thousands of people by now.
I mean personally in all these different
talks and everybody wants something
done about it,
which is one of the things I thought
about the electronic health records and
getting, because that would at
least get us off the computer.
It's not complicated.
I don't think it's as complicated as
solution as it looks like at first.
If we can just get back the time.
Okay. Yeah, sure.
Since we're at Google,
um,
be curious about your comment on the use
of Google glass in the doctor patient
setting.
So clinic that I will not name has
now gone to using Google glasses.
So you walk into the clinic room,
your doctor has a Google glass on and on
the other side of the Google glass is a
transcriptionist probably in India,
somewhere outsourced.
That is documenting every single word
that it occurs between you and your
position during that encounter.
So it's some ways its off sitting,
it's taking more time. The doctor
doesn't have to do the data entry,
but there's this third person in the
room through the Google glass that you're
wonderful. An amazing company has
enabled doctors to use this technology,
but it has affected the
doctor patient interaction.
Many of my colleagues who are using it
claim that it's given back their lives,
that they're now completing all of their
charting within the course of the day.
They're going home and they're not taking
their charts home with them because
they don't have to because everything is
transcribed for them. But I'm wondering,
you know from all of you and from you
what your perspective on this as a
possible solution would be.
That seems to me, not a solution
but impossible problem. I mean,
I just, you know, it's like I was just
horrified when I, when I heard about that.
I mean,
I can't imagine anything worse than
going into my patient like this.
Hi,
I'm doctor [inaudible] and trying to
look at the Google glass in their records
out of the corner of my eye,
it just seems whacked. Um,
there is something called the scribe,
which gives me the same feeling,
which is doctors, so they don't
have to sit in front of computer.
Now there's an actual physical third
person who follows you in the room and
fills out your electronic health records
while you supposedly are talking with a
patient, which is a lot
better solution, I think,
than the Google glass where at least
you're physically looking at the person.
But Rebecca,
do you have any thoughts on Google?
Well,
actually I,
I had a clinician who wanted to do that
and I was uncomfortable and she did give
me an option that you didn't mention,
which is what I was uncomfortable with
was Google glass is about looking at
things.
It's not just about audio transcription
and so it could be beaming images.
Right.
Which feels like it could be a violation
of the page and patients' privacy.
So there were two modes.
So the mode that I allowed her
to use was just recording audio.
But even so that I where I felt as an
imposition in that trust relationship.
Okay.
Personal anyway. Anything
else? Oh yes please.
That you have to have a paper trial,
absolutely everything and that that's
part of what's inhibiting your efficiency.
Can you say that a little bit?
How much of it is driven by legal reasons
and not like big data and collecting?
Oh, I see what you're having in paper
towel and yes, he says, well we have,
you know, we do like to document things
for, you know, for malpractice reasons,
but if you just handwrite it,
it's perfectly fine.
Doesn't have to be in a
computer per se at all. Um,
so there's no reason that we have to
have a clumsy electronic health record.
It takes all our time and produces
big data in order to document.
It's actually a much better documentation
if I actually write the story about
you.
You know,
this 32 year old woman came
in with chronic headaches
and I thought this and we
did this and this is what I think it is
kind of story than it is to have what I
found with my father, which was
incomprehensible. So it's not,
that's not the legal thing. There is
a legal piece that the United States,
the one reason we've gone to having
electronic health records was then in 2009
there was hidden in the
reconstructing America Act.
This little infant, they
called it, sorry, uh, this,
this little sub La thingy that every
doctor that has anything to do with the
federal government I think has to
have their electronic health records.
That's how it happened.
It didn't happen gradually.
It was like 2009 then they would start
taking money out of your practice if you
didn't have electronic records.
So it was one of the reasons that suddenly
they took this billing platform and
just immediately tried to add
things on so they could sell it.
The doctors and the doctors can do that.
So there is some legal piece of that,
but it isn't so much like getting Sudi
kind of thing. It's more like government.
I do want to point out that Dr Suite
has one of the few people on the planet
who's actually read the
entire affordable care act,
922 single spaced pages.
It's as long as Harrison's principles of
internal medicine. Okay. On that note,
thank you very much.
Thank you very much for having me.